if you've been following cyberpunk 2077
you probably know how deadly mega
corporations like militech and arasaka
can be
not only can corporate conflicts be
waged economically but many regimes are
enforced through violence
theft and arson some of these conflicts
play out in smaller arenas a gunfight in
the streets of night city or an
assassination attempt on upper
management
however if there's enough resources at
play these contained conflicts can
expand
into full-blown multi-court battles this
is what we call
a corporate war although there were
three corporate wars prior to the fourth
obviously the fourth corporate war
played a big part in shaping the
corporate cultural and environmental
landscape of cyberpunk's universe
even though the war ended 50 years
before the events of cyberpunk 2077
remnants of the war are and always will
be present in night city
but before we dig into the fourth
corporate war let's take a look back at
the previous corporate wars
from 2004 to 2016 corporations were
involved in three distinct wars
most of these conflicts were fought by
security personnel and mercenaries with
high-tech weaponry
the first war was between epic games and
apple
i mean ebm and orbital air for control
over the remains of the failing company
transworld airlines ultimately orbital
air forced ebm to surrender and they
took control of transworld airlines
assets
although this war only lasted from 2004
to 2006 it set a dangerous precedent for
other corporations it meant that
violence and warfare were viable tactics
many corporations beefed up their
security departments when the dust
settled i say when the dust settled but
the dust from corporate warfare didn't
have much time to settle
in 2006 the second corporate war kicked
off
this time the major players were two
massive oil companies petrochem and
sovoil
oil companies engaged in deceit
clandestine warfare and underhanded
tactics
that's the first time i've heard of
something like that while petrochem did
significant damage to silve oil it
ultimately lost the battle with sovoil
coming out on top but the war wreaked
havoc on the world
most notably the southern pacific rim
became a cesspool of pollution and oil
according to cyberpunk 2020 firestorm
stormfront try saying that five times
fast the south china sea became a
lifeless chemical stew all but
inhabitable today
nations and economies were destroyed in
the fallout and so voyle was forced to
pay reparations the second corporate war
was also the first time a corporation
blatantly ignored governments and
nations in order to secure a victory
the third corporate war played out a
little differently than the last two due
to the fact that it was mostly fought on
the net
this war was between investment
councillors meryl asukaga and finch and
the rothstein fund a subsidiary of the
bank of new york
manf was embezzling money from the
rothstein fund when the rothstein fund
uncovered
manf's scheme they notified the los
angeles district attorney's office
manf retaliated by launching a netrunner
assault on the rothstein fund
a few months later manf left the corpses
of two rothstein execs
on the da's doorsteps the rostine fund
dissolved shortly after
the worst was yet to come for night city
in 2021 a german nautical tech company
by the name of
in inter international
handles marine act
or ihag for short came into some
financial trouble two competing nautical
companies caught wind of ihack's
financial downturn
and both attempted to swoop in and take
control of the sinking
pun intended nautical corp those
companies were ocean technology and
energy corporation
otech for short and a french company i'm
not going to try to pronounce
which we'll call sino for short i hag
otech and ceno had been ruthless
competitors for years
vying for economic dominance in marine
biotechnology when ihack filed for
bankruptcy otec encino opened bids to
acquire the company
unfortunately before a ceno negotiator
could present a buyout offered to ihag
she was kidnapped i wonder who or what
could have been behind that
wasting no time at all otech signed a
protection security contract with
militech a huge tech and weapons
corporation that had been in competition
with arasaka for years
of course this caused ceno to partner up
with arasaka the japanese-based
mega-corporation
this more or less kicked off a proxy war
between militech and arasaka officially
both corps are trying to sway the
outcome of the ihag
takeover unofficially the two major
corporations found a reason to launch a
clandestine conflict known as the shadow
war
most of the attacks during this period
consisted of assassination theft and net
raids between arasaka and militech
the shadow raids didn't last long though
as the covert operations of both
companies came to a head
war broke loose known as the hot war
many corpse and security specialists
picked aside and fighting broke out in
all major cities worldwide
at this point the dispute between ceno
and otech had been resolved but the two
massive security corps were just getting
started this squabble was shaping up to
be much bigger than the corporate wars
before it both sides were escalating the
conflict every chance they got
investing heavily in weapons technology
very few parts of the world were off
limits and entire economies societies
and cultures suffered because of it most
notably in 2023
international trade collapsed the net
also suffered from the conflict
it was rife with deadly programs and
dark areas thanks to militech and
arasaka's handiwork netwatch the
internet police couldn't contain the
virtual damage either
eventually the pre-fourth corporate war
net deteriorated
and died 2023 was also the same year
that johnny silverhand and solo morgan
blackhand along with a group of
anarchists
raided the arasaka building and night
city to destroy arasaka's secured
database
for more info on this pivotal event in
johnny's life be sure to check out our
video on johnny silverhand
right after this this raid didn't quite
go as planned and a nuclear device was
set off destroying central night city
and killing three quarters of a million
people it's unclear who detonated the
nuke some believe it was arasaka to
protect corporate secrets
while others believe it to be militech
finally the united states government
stepped in and nationalized militech
forcing arasaka out of the united states
with militech at her back u.s president
elizabeth cress used this as an
opportunity to take full control of the
government and reunify the united states
of course the free state of northern
california was uninterested in
reunification due to northern
california's disobedience crest did not
aid night city and its reconstruction
efforts
and this brings us to the time of the
red but we'll save that for another
video
the fourth corporate war was a wake up
call for the world although governments
and nations still
existed it became apparent that
corporations were calling the shots
allegiances didn't lie in world leaders
or countries but in arasaka or militech
and of course
i'm sure we'll see more of this bitter
rivalry between militech and arasaka in
cyberpunk 2077.
thank you so much for watching this
episode of cyberpunk lore
be sure to check back every saturday for
a new episode and if there's something
you'd like us to discuss
leave it in the comments below or you
can drop me a line on twitter
see you next time
you